[Music]
it's no surprise with the Netflix
romantic comedy to all the boys I've
loved before has become super popular
after all is based on an amazing
best-selling novel by Jenny Han ever
wondered what the differences are
between the book and the movie stay
tuned to find out the biggest change the
movie made if you love Keeping Up with
all the details about your favorite
movies and TV shows be sure to subscribe
now let's get to the major differences
between the book and the movie to all
the boys I've loved before has totally
stolen our hearts it's the cutest love
story and we just can't get enough of
Lara Jean Covey and Peter Kavinsky in
the story Lara Jean is a shy girl with a
huge crush on her sister's ex-boyfriend
Laura Jean has a tradition of writing
long love letters to her crushes and she
keeps those letters in a hat box in her
closet there are five letters in total
and they go back several years these
letters get sent out to the boys which
is pretty much the most embarrassing
thing ever
Peter the most popular guy in school
confronts Laura Dean she hasn't had a
crush on him in years but Laura wants to
make sure that Josh her sister's ex
doesn't find out that she's in love with
him and Peter wants to make his ex
jealous the two decide to have a fake
relationship and they create a
relationship contract but Peter ends up
being pretty much the perfect boyfriend
he and Laura Jean fall in love for real
we love stories with fake dating that
turns into real love there is some other
drama going on but the movie has a happy
ending Peter and Laura Jean actually get
together at the end of the movie to all
the boys I've loved before is one of
three books about Laura Jean and Peter
it's totally possible that there could
be a sequel or two on Netflix that would
be the best news ever but the movie made
a few major changes and even borrowed
plot points from the other books what
were the biggest changes in the movie
stay tuned to find out don't forget to
have fun I have a lot of rubbers
specifically the hot tub scene in both
the book and the movie Lara Jean and
Peter have a steamy make-out session in
the hot tub on the ski trip the hot tub
has a reputation of the school for being
the place where lots of couples do a lot
more than kiss for the first time
despite the package of protection Laura
jeans dad gives her Lara Jean and Peter
only do some major kissing then some
drama ensues and Laura Jean breaks up
with Peter so what is the drama
Genevieve is to blame in both the movie
and the novel she is the meanest mean
girl and she is also Peters
ex-girlfriend in the book Genevieve
tells Lara Jean but there is a rumor
going around of course Genevieve started
it people believe that Peter and Lara
Jean went all the way in the hot tub but
Genevieve says that Peter did not deny
it when he was asked Lara Jean is
immortal ID and she avoids Peter over
all of Chris's prank in the movie
Genevieve instead Taos Laura Jean that
Peter spent the night in her room after
he made out with Lara Jean in the hot
tub Lara Jean things Peter cheated on
her after saying he wanted a real
relationship so she ends things with him
but it turns out Peter just went to
officially end things with Genevieve the
video that gets leaked onto Instagram
does not happen in the first book it
actually happens at the beginning of the
second book PS I love you right you
think I'm whiskey it's cold outside I
don't do cold John Ambrose McLaren John
Ambrose McLaren Laura jeans former love
interest is one of the letter recipients
the two meet at model.you in which Laura
Jean doesn't participate in any more
they don't go to the same school in the
book John Ambrose is mentioned a lot
when Lara Jean starts falling for Peter
she tries to distract herself with John
Ambrose she even goes to a Model UN
meetup to potentially see him but she
chickens out and runs away when he
notices her in the movie we pretty much
don't hear about him after the beginning
but then the final scene has John
Ambrose showing up at large in store
with flowers in PS I still love you John
Ambrose writes back to Laura Jean and
they exchange letters for a while before
they meet up we love that the
he shocked us with his appearance
Anderson is the neighbor of the coffee
family they grew up together and he was
originally large Eames friends as they
grew up Josh began to date Margot Laura
jeans older sister but Lara Jean falls
for him and that violates every sister
code ever when Margo breaks up with Josh
in the movie it's a huge deal Josh comes
over for her farewell dinner and he
surprises her
he bought tickets to come visit her in
Scotland over Thanksgiving break Margo
freaks out because she doesn't want to
start college in a new country with a
boyfriend back home they have a huge
fight outside and Margo breaks up with
him it's really sad and we totally feel
for Josh but in the book it just happens
quietly there's no huge fight about it
at dinner and Margo tells Laura Jean
about it the next morning Josh and Lara
Jean were really close friends until the
letters went out in the movie Lara Jean
makes a huge effort to avoid Josh all
the time he doesn't have a huge role in
the movie at all but he does in the book
he makes several appearances and when he
confesses that he has similar feelings
for Laura Jean he kisses her that does
not happen in the movie Margo is even
more upset when she finds out about that
but she eventually forgives Laura Jean
when Josh
kisses vah regime in the book this is
when she realizes that she no longer has
any feelings for him this is a major
turning point because she can't deny her
feelings for Peter anymore so what are
you like this movie why are you even
asking that question hello Jake Ryan
Peter and Laura James first and second
kiss Laura jeans first kiss was with
Peter Kavinsky in middle school that
much is true in both the book in the
movie but how that kiss happened is
totally different in the movie that
kisses way more innocent at that time
Laura Jean and Genevieve were best
friends
soon Aviv had a crush on Peter but at
the party the kids play spin the bottle
and does that bring back memories when
Laura Jean spins the bottle it lands on
Peter o-m-g Lara Jean feels bad that she
has to kiss her besties crash and it's
just a really quick peck on the lips
because it was a game and such an
innocent kiss Genevieve's years long
grudge against Laura Jean is pretty AF
the kiss happens very differently in the
book middle school Peter definitely had
a crush on Laura Jean they were the last
two kids waiting for their parents at
the party Peter in true romantic middle
school fashion tells Laura Jean that she
smells good then he just plans to wet
one right on her lips by the time the
letters go out Laura Jean is over Peter
Peter is super popular and Laura Jean is
not their second kiss happened after the
letters get sent out in the book Peter
confronts her and says he just isn't
attracted to her she tells him she wrote
the letter a long time ago back in
middle school later she hides from Josh
in the tree house when Josh confronts
her at her locker the next day Laura
Jean tells him she's dating someone else
then she runs up to Peter in the hallway
and kisses him and oh my gosh he kisses
her back she explains her situation
about being in love with her sister's
axe and Peter agrees to go along with
the fake relationship in the movie when
Peter confronts Laura Jean it's on the
track during her PE class she literally
faints she swears to him she isn't
interested but then she sees Josh
walking up oh no she throws herself on
top of Peter and kisses him right then
it's hilarious and embarrassing and we
love the scene
Josh walks off hurt movie Peter is the
one who suggests the fake relationship
to Laura Jean instead of the other way
around
stop that
Laura jeans BFF in both the book and the
movie we meet Chris
she is Laura Jane's oldest and best
friend and she is also Genevieve's
cousin but we don't see a whole lot of
Chris in the movie we see her stand up -
Genevieve at the beginning but she
doesn't do much else it's almost like
Laura Jean doesn't have a best friend in
the movie because Chris's role is so
small but Chris has a much bigger role
in the book we find out a lot more about
her she is the polar opposite of Lauren
she is wild she goes to a lot of parties
and messes around with boys she and
Margo can't stand each other and when
Lara Jean is trying to figure out who
could have sent the letters she even
considers Chris as a possibility we
aren't sure why Chris's character was
downplayed in the movie so much she is
an awesome character the relationship
contract when Laura Jean and Peter
decide to have a fake relationship Lara
Jean insists on writing up a contract
the contract is mostly the same but
there are a few differences first of all
they both agree not to have much PDA in
the movie Laura Jean ever the romantic
says that Peter can put his hand in her
back pocket in the book that is Peters
idea we aren't sure his motivations are
quite as pure and romantic as Laura
jeans also there's a cute scene in the
film where they talk about the movies
Fight Club and sixteen Candles they put
in the contract that Lara Jean must
watch Fight Club and Peter must watch
sixteen Candles in the book they write
in the contract that Peter won't make
Laura Jean watch action movies if she
won't make him watch romantic comedies
Peter and Laura jeans interactions there
are a few scenes that are changed
between these two fake lovebirds when
Peter and Lara Jean first interacts in
the movie Laura Jane almost hits him
with her car because she's such a
terrible driver in the book he helps her
with some car trouble he's such a good
guy we never find out exactly what Laura
jeans letter to Peter says in the movie
he definitely mentions the embarrassing
line about having golden specks in his
eyes but in the book Lara Jean wrote
something even more embarrassing when he
could
sir the book Peter tells her that he
doesn't have an STD we wonder what
happened in middle school that made
Laura Jean think that about him poor
Laura Jean she must have been mortified
in the book when he has said that
another difference is the scrunchie from
the movie at the party Lara Jean tells
Peter not to lose the scrunchie because
it's her favorite genevieve stills it
out of jealousy that night Lara Jean
sees Genevieve with it after the ski
trip which she sees as proof that Peter
cheated even though he didn't Genevieve
even tells her that Peter gave her the
scrunchie but in the book Peter just
takes Laura jeans hair down with a
regular hair tie and tosses it on the
grass says you dr. Mann puts a goddess
within two this is shake it for them
that represents the deepest celebration
of womanhood
Kitty and the letters in both the book
and the movie kitty is the one who sins
out Laura jeans love letters but in the
novel it's a huge mystery Laura Jean
spends a lot of time trying to figure
out who sent them in the movie we see
Kitty sneak into large ins closet and
pull down the Hat box and she acts
totally guilty about it when she
realizes how much drama
it caused kitty is younger in the book
than the movie she also comes across
more spoil than the Netflix version but
the biggest difference is why Kitty
sends the letters in the movie Kitty
really just wants the best for Laura
Jean she makes comments about Laura Jean
having no social life somehow kitty
knows about the letters and she decides
to help her sister out by mailing them
she really wants Laura Jean to be happy
although she probably shouldn't have
done what she did kitty from the book
sends the letters out of anger can he
also had a crush on Josh apparently he
is just irresistible to the Cubby
sisters when Laura Jean almost slips off
and reveals Kitty's crush
kitty gets super mad she sends off the
letter as revenge she does feel bad
about it at the end of the book though
so at least she learned her lesson the
ending the biggest difference is how the
book and the movie end since we don't
find out about the video until the
second book we don't see Peter stand up
for Laura Jean until then Laura Jean
does not make up with Peter at the end
of the first book instead the book ends
with her writing the love letter to him
in
margene reads a letter to Peter on the
lacrosse field then the to share the
hottest kiss ever even with the
differences we still adore both versions
do you prefer the book or the movie let
us know in the comments those are the
biggest changes between the book and the
movie versions of to all the boys I've
loved before don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up for more awesome
content click subscribe see you next
time
[Music]